[Aplausos]
hace algunos años que soy docente de
ajedrez y siempre me interesó ver qué
aprendizajes del juego podía aplicar a
mi vida cotidiana la mayor enseñanza que
tuve está relacionado con cómo se llega
al desenlace de una partida y esa
enseñanza es que yo no pierdo la partida
en el momento en el que me dan jaque
mate yo no pierdo la partida en el
momento en el que el otro jugador toma
la torre la lleva a la última fila y me
da mate yo pierdo la partida mucho antes
de eso cuando mi rival me obliga a
elegir entre dos malas jugadas
seguramente durante el transcurso de la
partida quince o veinte movidas antes
que esto mi rival me obliga a decidir
entre el que me coman la torre o el
caballo
hoy en muchos barrios los chicos sueñan
con ser futbolistas o soldaditos de la
droga lo digo en serio
en los recreos en el patio se paran en
la puerta del salón o del baño y cuando
les preguntas que están haciendo te
dicen campana
y los otros los que quieran ser
jugadores de fútbol hablan de llegar de
poder salvarse
todo lo hemos escuchado alguna vez
incluso escuchamos a los padres de los
chicos decir estoy viendo si con el pibe
me salvó
y muchas movidas después nos toca hablar
con gente que nos dice que se roba
porque quiere ese es eligió ser un
drogadicto si está bien es verdad lo
eligió pero no será que quince o veinte
movidas antes en su partida lo obligamos
a mover entre dos malas jugadas que lo
llevaron hoy a que esté con la partida
perdida
de los que están acá por ejemplo todos
eligieron venir no más allá de algún
novio o novia está perdonado el resto
vino porque quiso bien ahora va es una
pregunta para el público que levanten la
mano de los mayores de edad los que
pudieron terminar la secundaria de los
que están acá
bueno si vemos
creo que la mayoría bueno gracias y
ahora voy a preguntar de los que
levantaron la mano recién quienes
tuvieron la oportunidad de empezar a
estudiar algo lo hayan terminado o no
bueno
veo que tenemos una característica en
común además de ser muy lindos y
agradables todos
ahora realmente piensan que es
casualidad que estemos acá los que
estemos no serán que nuestras partidas
diez o quince movidas antes elegimos al
alguna jugada que no se empezó a
conducir hasta el día de hoy
yo tengo un amigo email
con el que hace muchas movidas atrás
estábamos jugando a una vida una partida
similar vivíamos en un barrio alejado
del centro y demás está decir que cuando
seamos grandes queríamos ser jugadores
de fútbol si todavía no estaban de moda
los bunker y los soldaditos así que
queríamos ser jugadores de fútbol
cuando decidí que va a nombrarlo ismael
en la charla fiesta a su casa a contarle
y a pedirle permiso primero me preguntó
que eran las charlas ted después me
felicitó
y por último me pidió disculpas por no
poder venir que le hubiera encantado
pero ismael hace un tiempo que estaba
con prisión domiciliaria
ya estuvo en la cárcel el tiempo que
tenía que estar y está cumpliendo lo que
le queda en su casa él tuvo que elegir
entre dos malas jugadas
hoy tengo 24 años y como verán no soy
juez de fútbol
pero tampoco soy soldadito entonces qué
fue lo que pasó
hace unas cuantas movidas y años atrás
en mi partida estaba empezando la
secundaria y había dejado de jugar al
fútbol porque no me daban los horarios
para poder ir a entrenar
para colmo en la escuela no me lleva
también
aunque mis notas eran aceptables pero la
seño cada tanto llamaba a mi mamá para
contarle que mi comportamiento no era
acorde a lo que la institución profesaba
les digo la verdad me aburría y
molestaba mucho así que cualquier excusa
para poder escaparme el salón la
aceptaba
me acuerdo el día que me invitaron a
participar de la olimpiada de
matemáticas si iba podía ir y no hacer
nada fantástico y además zafaba de la
hora de biología que de biología lo más
lindo era bianca la hija de la profe
pero bueno en biología hablaba de
células procariotas y eucariotas que de
ella así que acepté me anoté y qué pasa
hoy tantas movidas después tengo la
posibilidad de ser docente de ajedrez y
olimpiada de matemática de ser el
presidente de una asociación deportiva
la de hanball y de presidir una
asociación cultural
y cuanto pasó y lo más importante que
tuve yo que no tuvo ismael
yo no era para nada más inteligente que
él vivíamos en el mismo contexto y los
dos agarramos cualquier trabajito para
poder hacer unos pesos para salir el fin
de semana
cuando lo pienso bien me di cuenta que
lo que yo tuve fue editor mi profes
olimpiada de matemáticas de la escuela
ella me invitaba a su casa a la tarde a
la hora de la merienda para poder
prestar me algunos libros de
entrenamiento yo en ese momento no tenía
acceso a computer net y mucho menos a
libros de matemáticas así que cuando lo
pienso bien creo que tuve edith que me
dio más opciones para mover es decir
tuve las malas jugadas las tuve pero
también tuve algunas que eran buenas y
lo digo hoy con el resultado opuesto con
la partida avanzada en ningún momento me
hubiera imaginado que mover un peón en
ese entonces me iba a llevar hasta esta
situación de privilegio donde puedo
hacer lo que me hace feliz y estoy
orgulloso de eso esa es mi definición de
privilegio
y ahora yo pienso
todos los días si hay algo que podamos
hacer para que todos los chicos y las
chicas puedan elegir entre más opciones
en cada movida o era acaso
responsabilidad del estado de los
políticos del ministerio de desarrollo
social que dice destine su única hora
libre de la semana a dar un taller
gratuito de olimpiada de matemática no
creo que hay mucho para hacer y por eso
me aguanto los reproches y las críticas
de siempre por ejemplo vas a estar toda
la tarde en una en una actividad
cultural te vas a pasar el día de la
madre en un torneo de handball para que
organizarse ese torneo de ajedrez si no
te pagan
lo de siempre
la otra enseñanza que me dejó el ajedrez
es que no necesariamente gana el que
tiene más piezas sino que gana el que
hace trabajar en conjunto a las que
tiene en pos de un plan de una
estrategia si todos los que estamos acá
que pensamos que hay algo para hacer y
todos los que están afuera que piensan
lo mismo que nosotros no nos juntamos la
partida está perdida
creo que somos muchos pero que nos
dejamos guiar por los comentarios de
siempre que esto no tiene arreglo que
los argentinos somos así que los
latinoamericanos somos así
y el más clásico y el que más me duele
que la juventud está perdida
no hablo de hacer matemática hanball o
ajedrez esas fueron las movidas que yo
tuve las opciones que yo tuve y entre
las que yo elegí hablo de hacer un
taller de crochet telas yoga circo de
donar fondos y ver que sean bien usados
de meterse en la comisión directiva de
un club para ayudar a levantarlo todo
suma todo suma pero en sintonía con el
otro de nada nos sirve tener un profe de
radio que quiera dar un taller si no
tenemos a la biblioteca popular que le
consiga los elementos y si no tenemos a
los padres de los chicos del barrio que
estén convencidos de que es importante
de que aprendan a relacionarse y a decir
lo que piensan
tenemos que organizarnos porque los que
vienen trabajando organizados son los
que contratan a nuestros chicos como
soldaditos de la droga ellos son menos
pero trabajan como una pieza de
relojería
podemos hacer algo o podemos no hacer
nada pero cuidado porque no hacer nada
también es hacer algo solo que en ese
caso no sabemos a qué intereses
favorecemos un jugador de ajedrez cuando
termina una partida la analiza trata de
ver dónde se equivocó cuándo y si podía
hacer algo para solucionarlo para
evitarlo y por qué lo hace porque puede
ser que en otra partida llega hasta una
posición similar y pueda tomar una mejor
decisión y eso es lo bueno del ajedrez
no importa si me hacen elegir entre dos
malas jugadas si me dan mate o incluso
si me canso y no quiero jugar más esa
partida total puedo ir agarro nuevamente
las piezas las llevo y las acomodo en su
posición inicial y vuelvo a empezar
ahora la pregunta que les dejo es vos
voz todos ustedes los pibes
tienen otra partida para volver a
intentar gracias
[Aplausos]